moving on now let me contrast to mutual
mistake with what in law is called your
lateral mistake a mistake that is only
one-sided one party is under an
important mistaken impression and the
other is not I start with a case that
never happened because the outcome is so
clear that nobody would even think about
arguing about it suppose I'm a gambler
on the horses and I've got a horse right
here his name is Paul Revere and a guy
has told me and if the weather is clear
can do so thinking I've got a good bet I
go to the paramutual window at the
racetrack and I put down a hundred
dollars on Paul Revere to win the
weather is clear but unfortunately Paul
Revere doesn't even finish in the top
three can't do now I obviously made a
mistake a bad mistake a bad gamble but
the track didn't make a mistake nobody I
was gambling with made a mistake
it was my mistake it was my gamble and I
ended up losing obviously I can't go
back to the window and say hey I made a
mistake can I get my money back no I was
just wrong too bad so in a unilateral
mistake the contract is still binding
here's a more difficult case this one
actually happened see how you think it
ought to turn out the buyer is a
collector of rare coins and the seller
is a coin dealer they're both experts
the buyer sees in the seller stock a
coin that claims to be a 1916 dime
minted in Denver a coin like that is a
particular rarity it's worth $500
in fact the dealer some time before had
bought it for 450 dollars the buyer
looks at the coin very carefully takes
out his magnifying glass really checks
it out and the seller says I'm gonna
charge you $500 for it I paid 450 for it
which is true so if I can get a small
profit it's yours for 500 the buyer says
I wanted I've always wanted a 1916
Denver dime for my collection
it's a deal he buys it for $500 not long
after that another coin collector learns
that the buyer had this rare 1916 Denver
dime and he says I want that I'll pay
you $700 for it but of course first I
have to get it certified by the American
Numismatic Society he does and it turns
out that the coin is a very clever faith
now the first buyer wants to get his
money back one lower court said that the
buyer of the coin the guy who paid $500
was out of luck this kind of thing is
not like buying a standard grain of
wheat by the carload and finding that
you've been sold some other grade or
that some of the wheat has spoiled or
sprouted this is an inherently risky
business buying and selling antiques is
always something of a gamble and both
sides were gambling and the buyer lost
it would be quite a different story if
the seller of the coin had known that it
was a forgery or indeed it fortunate
himself that's cheating
but neither side was cheating they were
both taking their chances and so the
court below said it's a little bit like
betting on the horse Paul Revere however
that's not
what the higher court the appellate
court said the court that reviewed that
decision the appellate court said that
they were both equally innocent both
equally persuaded neither of them
thought they were gambling and therefore
since they were both mistaken it was
like the two ships peerless or rows of
abalone a mutual mistake the deal was
called off what do you think do you
agree